about there being evidence there's
someone named kevin knuth or kevin knuth
i don't know if you've heard of him he's
a physicist from albany you've heard of
him yes definitely okay well i'm
speaking to him in a few hours just for
people listening to i'm speaking to him
in a few hours he says that he's
analyzed some of the data of the ufos or
uaps i believe they're called now and he
showed that through analysis
the amount of acceleration is
incomparable to anything that we can
produce and
it's well i guess you can take that as
evidence
what do you think about that have you
seen that paper of his so
anything to do with unidentifying flying
objects or aerial phenomena
my take on those uh is simple that
we should deploy state-of-the-art
instruments uh cameras or uh audio
sensors in the same locations and try to
collect data just like a scientific
experiment
rather than rely on instruments that
were not optimized for that purpose that
you know pilots have access to and
uh or rely on reports that came from
many years ago that we cannot really
check
um and so i think that
all the ufo and uap
supporters should fund a scientific
mission
experiment to monitor the earth
yeah monitor those locations if you
think that they are and basically if we
see anything unusual
it will be documented in a
scientifically credible way
rather than rely on those unoptimized
reports that you know the images are
always fuzzy it could be something in
the instrument it could be
something else in the sky that is an
optical illusion could be many things
so um
i would highly recommend doing a
scientific credible scientific
experiment then you know it shouldn't be
too expensive and it would save us a lot
of time instead of discussing it let's
just let we should let the evidence
dictate